flatten it down the idea now is to get a
little small balls okay cut it in half
okay and then each half into quarter and
then we'll go into quarters cut them
into half or do that with your hands
basically looking for a sort of from
golf ball shape okay
okay I'm gonna make these nice little
sort of patties they're called but
almost like a little mini burger but
don't get too okay put them on there
yeah onto the plate so they don't stick
okay nice and I have to fatten out a
little bit more than that I'm gonna cook
baby happy now now now right
don't you feel sorry for the lamb now
look you do good girl am losing in
Bradford how are you buds coming on my
darling Oh
mm-hmm she's ignoring really sorry
garden this is so strong it's making my
eyes yeah
stay with me this will be delicious is
the most amazing Shami kabab right stay
with you yummy
thank god you're in Bradford right okay
that's nice careful I give a little flap
little fatter okay I seen it before we
can do that in the pan as well yep now
the secret dividing the mince into sort
of four and again into half is that they
cook evenly okay eight little golf ball
shapes Pat them down and this smells
amazing how's your min talent yeah
lovely how she'd even sever that a mile
to biography
you won't bugs got a good sexy warm yeah
okay now okay now shake them Busey I Pat
them down it smells amazing
stay with me Ellen come on you can do
this you're not something you'd find in
a poker face come on right the pan
should be nice and hot now okay ground
nut oil into the pan like a tablespoon
of oil get that nice and hot okay as it
starts to smoke well then good yes
kebabs in be very careful place these in
because the mint is quite soft okay nice
and gently done okay we season the mix
okay Allen are the in the pan
yep they're in the pan okay now this is
the first time ever in a professional
kitchen yeah yeah my god I used to learn
I never get on with chefs we used to do
a lot home waiter in osoo say you're
gonna hate me because you know what I
could own the old two plates you know
those microwave it up like that and I'll
come in and just like they hate me right
they're cooking now we're gonna do the
yogurt sauce okay so the rest of you
mint okay and chop that meat up nice and
finely yeah now okay not all the
thoughts just the top well done mint in
okay a little bit of salt
okay little bit of pepper and let's s
our lime take your line and zest that
love okay those so now it's a rare yet
good you can borrow my mill if you wish
now zesting the lime this makes a really
nice sort of fresh fragrant delicious
sauce it's sort of cool down the kabobs
give that little stir okay and leave
that sitting there now whilst you do
that just stay ahead of the game lay out
a serving plate ready to serve those
kabobs
place our Alan
what place up right now okay now okay
we're going to turn those kebab very
very gently okay okay right